The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Our lesson today involves
a rather subtle difference
between a curve and
a coordinate system.
In other words, given a curve,
that curve has a certain shape,
has a certain
position, independently
of where our coordinate
axes are if we're
using Cartesian coordinates,
or whether we're
using other coordinate
systems, or what have you,
but the equation of
the curve may very well
depend on what coordinate
system we're using.
The thing that we would like to
do in this particular lecture
is to hit a very important
highlight that comes up-- well,
you can motivate it from a
purely mathematical point
of view, but physically
there's an even more
natural interpretation.
And basically what
the thing hinges on
is this: If you're
given a curve in space--
we'll start with a
curve in the plane,
but it applies to
curves in space as well.
Given that curve
in the plane, does
that curve have certain
properties regardless
of whether you know what your
coordinate system is or not?
Or in still other words, can you
measure the shape of the curve,
can you measure the
speed along the curve
as a particle traverses
it, if you had never
heard of the x- and
y-coordinate system?
And what this leads
to is a new system
of vectors by which we
study motion in space
called tangential and
normal vectors when
we're dealing in the plane.
And there's a third number
called the binormal vector,
which we'll talk about
later when we deal
in three-dimensional space.
Any rate, just for brevity, I
call this lecture "Tangential
and Normal Vectors".
And the idea is
something like this.
We're given a curve C. Now,
given this particular curve C,
it happens that we have a
Cartesian coordinate system
here.
And it also happens
that we prefer,
at least as we've done
things in the past,
we write everything in
terms of i and j components.
Notice that if a person were
restricted to his universe
being the curve C, i and j
have no basic meaning to him.
What does have a
basic meaning to him,
as he's moving along this curve,
I would imagine, would be what?
What is his motion
tangential to the curve?
In other words, if you want to
look at this from a calculus
point of view, if this
is a smooth curve,
in a sufficiently small
neighborhood of this point,
you cannot distinguish between
the curve and the tangent line.
And consequently,
one could interpret
that at a given instance
the motion was always
along the straight line
tangential to the curve.
What this leads to is
the notion of inventing
what we call a unit tangent
vector, which I'll call T.
And what is that tangent vector?
It's not a constant, mind you.
It shifts with position as
you move along the curve.
What is constant
is its magnitude.
It has constant magnitude 1.
I guess what I'm
trying to say, in sort
of a surrealistic or
metamathematical way,
is that T plays to a person
who's living on the curve C
the same role that i
plays to a person living
in our ordinary space, but
somehow or other he sees T
as a constant vector as
he moves along the curve
If he visualizes the curve
as being a straight line.
He always sees it
tangential to his motion.
Now, in the same way that j was
a 90-degree positive rotation
of i, one would like
to mimic the i and j
Cartesian coordinate system
by inventing another unit
vector, which is again what?
A positive 90-degree
rotation of T.
And we'll call that vector N.
So that now we have a new
system of coordinates, T and N,
new system of
variables, or vectors,
whereby we can now study
motion along a curve in a very
natural way.
In other words, we talk about
the unit tangent direction
and the unit normal direction.
And we have this
thing now established.
What we would like
to do is to see
what happens in our study
of kinematics, motion
in the plane, motion in
space, if we work in terms
of tangential and
normal components now
rather than in terms
of i and j components.
The first thing that
we'd probably like to do
is figure out how in the
world do you compute T?
Well, for example, let's take
a particular application.
Let's take the example that
we were dealing with last time
where we had the radius
vector R-- in other the scalar
function t, where
t denoted time--
and we were dealing what?
Motion in space, where
the radius vector
R was a function of t.
And remember what
we showed last time?
We showed that the dR/dt, the
velocity vector, has its what?
Its direction is always
tangent to the curve.
We proved that last time.
Well, as long as
the dR/dt is always
tangent to the curve, what
prevents it from being a unit
tangent vector?
Well, nothing prevents it
from being a tangent vector,
because it's already
tangent to the curve.
All that could go wrong is
that the magnitude of the dR/dt
is not 1.
Well, lookit.
That's, again, a very
simple point to fix up.
Namely, if the magnitude
of dR/dt is not 1,
suppose we divide that
vector by its magnitude.
We have already seen that given
any non-zero vector, if you
divide that vector
by its magnitude,
you get the unit vector in the
same direction as the vector
that you started with.
In other words, if I take
the vector dR/dt, which
is already tangential to the
curve at the given point,
and I divide that by the
magnitude of the dR/dt,
then I automatically get
the unit tangent vector.
Is that clear?
Well, since nobody says
no, I assume it is clear.
Lookit.
We also showed last time
that the magnitude of dR/dt
is speed along the curve.
Speed along the curve
happens to be called ds/dt.
So, again, another name
for the unit tangent vector
is dR/dt divided by ds/dt.
By the chain rule,
we can cancel dt.
And by the way,
notice the chain rule
applies for vector functions
like this, the same
as it did in part
one of our course,
by virtue of what we
showed in the last unit--
namely, that every formula
for derivatives that
was true for scalar
functions also
happens to be true for what?
Vector functions of
a scalar variable.
At any rate, notice then by
the chain rule, another way
of saying T is that it's the
derivative of the position
vector R with respect
to the arc length s.
I'd like to make
one comment on this.
It's important enough
so that I will also
make this comment in
the notes as well when
we're doing the exercises.
The point is that
in many textbooks,
they will define T
by saying it's dR/ds.
Now, 999 times out
of 1,000-- in fact,
999 times out of 998
even-- you will never
be given R as a function of
arc length in the real world.
In the real world,
R is a function
of some parameter, usually time.
And the trouble that
happens is if you
try to use this
definition, you find
yourself trying to
convert things into s,
and this makes sort
of a mess for you.
The thing I would like to
show you-- and, by the way,
this does not depend
on t standing for time.
If t is any
variable-- and we show
this in the notes
in the exercises
again-- if t is any scalar,
if you differentiate R
with respect to that scalar,
and divide that result
by the magnitude of
this vector, you wind up
with the unit tangent vector.
In other words, in
a real-life problem,
do not worry about converting
R into a function of s.
Simply differentiate R
as it stands with respect
to the given variable,
divide by the magnitude
of the derivative,
and, presto, you
have the unit tangent vector.
Of course, you may
ask, if it's so simple
to do what I just said, why
is it that every book defines
it this way?
The answer is
rather interesting,
and that is, we
have just mentioned
that we would like to believe
that the shape of a curve
depends only on
the curve itself,
not on how we parameterize it.
The beauty of this
particular definition
simply says the natural
parameter is arc length--
namely, arc length
doesn't depend
on any coordinate system.
Given the curve,
start at any point
you want, and you can
measure the arc length.
So s is a very natural
parameter that does not depend
on the coordinate system.
In other words, by defining
the unit tangent vector
to be dR/ds, you have a
beautiful philosophically pure
mathematical definition, because
you have a definition which
does not depend on
any coordinate system
or any unnatural parameter.
But in practice, this is the
way we compute the unit tangent
vector.
The question that comes up is
how do you find the vector N?
And I'm going to show you the
traditional way of doing this
before I jazz it up with
a more modern approach.
Let's look at T over here.
Let's call phi the angle
that the unit tangent vector
makes with the curve here.
Notice that in terms of this
diagram, since the unit tangent
vector has magnitude 1,
the i component of it
will be cosine phi and the j
component will be sine phi.
In other words, T is equal to
cosine phi i plus sine phi j.
Let's just differentiate.
See, T is a function
of phi here.
Let's just take the derivative
of T with respect to phi,
and we get right
away-- remember, now,
we're getting the mileage
out of this basic definition
of derivative.
That hasn't changed
since last time.
We just differentiate
term by term here.
We get minus sine phi
i plus cosine phi j.
Right away we observe that dT
/ d phi is still a unit vector.
You see, it's components are
minus sine phi and cosine phi,
so its magnitude is still 1.
And its slope is cosine
phi over minus sine
phi, which is the negative
reciprocal of the slope here.
In other words,
what this shows us,
through the
traditional approach,
is that whatever vector
the dT / d phi is,
it's a unit vector
perpendicular to T.
By the way, what that tells
us right away is that dT / d
phi must be either
plus N or minus N
before we go any further.
Why?
Because we already saw that
positive N, the vector that we
called N, was a positive
90-degree rotation of T.
If we only knew
that dT / d phi was
a positive 90-degree
rotation rather
than a negative 90-degree
rotation, we'd be home free.
And, again, the beauty
of trigonometry,
in the non-surveyor's
sense of the word,
analytically is this-- that sort
of having a premonition of what
we'd like to be true,
we simply verify
the trigonometric identities
that the cosine of phi
plus 90 degrees
is minus sine phi,
and the sine of
phi plus 90 degrees
is cosine phi, so that
dT / d phi is what?
It's cosine phi
plus 90 degrees i,
plus sine phi plus 90 degrees j.
And if we now compare
this with this,
we notice that we have
exactly the same expression,
except that the angle has been
increased by a positive 90
degrees.
In other words, dT / d phi is
a positive 90-degree rotation
of T. Consequently, dT
/ d phi is the vector
that was called N. OK?
That's dT / d phi.
Now, let's go back
to our kinematics.
We have T and N now.
Let's talk about our
velocity vector v,
where R is still some
function of time.
By definition, v is dR/dt.
That isn't going to change.
V was dR/dt last time.
It's going to be
dR/dt this time.
It's going to be dR/dt
whenever we want to use it.
The only difference is
that instead of expressing
this in terms of i and j,
we now want to express it
in terms of T and N.
And notice that since v
has as its direction the
direction of the tangent line,
and as its magnitude ds/dt--
we saw that last time-- notice
that in terms of T, v is just
a scalar multiple of the unit
tangent vector T. And what
scalar multiple is it?
It's ds/dt.
All right.
All that says is what?
That v is the vector
in the direction of T
whose magnitude is ds/dt,
which is speed along the curve.
I now want to find a.
a is acceleration.
It's the same acceleration that
I was talking about before.
It's dv/dt.
The only thing that's
going to change now
is I am not going to change
the acceleration vector.
I am going to change how
it looks, because now I'm
going to try to find it in
terms of T and N components.
So what do I do here?
Look at this expression for v.
ds/dt is speed along the curve.
That changes from time
to time, in general.
The unit tangent vector T is
also a variable function of t,
unless T happens to
be a straight line
through the origin-- namely,
notice that the unit tangent
vector, even though it
always has unit length,
changes its direction as
we move along the curve.
So in other words, both of these
factors are functions of t.
Consequently, to differentiate
this with respect to t,
we must use the product rule.
And the fact that all of
our differentiation formulas
are true for vector
and scalar combinations
as well as for scalars, I
now use the regular product
rule-- namely,
it's the derivative
of the first factor
times the second,
plus the first factor times
the derivative of the second.
And I now have a expressed
in terms of two vectors, T
and the derivative of the
unit vector T with respect
to time t.
And somehow or other,
all that's wrong here
is I would like to get this
thing expressed in terms of N.
You see, when I'm working
with T and N components,
I want my answer to
depend on T and N.
Now, here's where I
become very shrewd.
And, by the way,
this is an insight
that, if you're going
to pick it up at all,
you're either born with it or
you pick it up with experience.
But you just have to
work with these things.
There are tricks, if
you want-- I guess
the novice calls them "tricks."
The expert calls it "keen
analytical insight."
The point is I want to get
an N out of this thing.
I already know how to express
N in terms of dT / d phi.
In fact, N is dT / d phi.
So what I do is I
take dT/dt and say,
let me write it so I can get a
dT / d phi factor out of this.
I also want everything to
be in terms of arc length
so I can ultimately have
an answer which doesn't
depend on a coordinate system.
So what I really do is
I use the chain rule
to express this factor in terms
of what?-- these three factors.
You see, according
to the chain rule,
the d phi here cancels
the d phi here,
the ds here cancels the ds
here, and all I'm saying
is that dT/dt can be written
as dT / d phi times d phi / ds
times ds/dt.
Now we're in very
good shape, you see.
dT / d phi we already know
is N. And ds/dt we already
know can go with this.
And the only new thing
that we have to worry about
is what is d phi / ds.
See, again what so often
happens, you apply logic,
you get to a certain
inescapable conclusion,
and then if you have
brand new terms,
you have a choice between
doing what?-- saying I
don't like the new terms,
I'm going to throw them away,
or saying I like the result,
I had better interpret
what this new term means.
All I want to show you
is, is that the d phi /
ds has a very natural
interpretation--
namely, what is d phi / ds.
Let me tell you what
it's called first.
It's usually denoted by
the Greek letter kappa,
and it's called curvature.
Its reciprocal, 1 over kappa,
is usually denoted by rho,
and it's called the
radius of curvature.
And I give you plenty
of drill on the stuff.
I just want to mention
what these words are now.
In fact, part of
the drill is that d
phi / ds is not a very
convenient thing to compute.
Usually you're given y
as some function of x.
And many of the drill problems
that we have in calculus
ask questions like, how do you
express d phi / ds in terms
of y, dy, dx, et cetera?
Those are problems that we can
get into in more detail as we
do the exercises.
But all I wanted to
do in this lecture
is to show you why d phi /
ds is such a natural thing.
Look at the curve s.
As you move along
this curve, notice
that the change in phi
with respect to s in a way
tells you how the shape
of the curve is changing.
In other words, d
phi / ds measures
how-- what could be a more
natural word than curvature?
See, as phi changes as you
move along the curve, that's
measuring how your
curvature is changing.
As an extreme case, notice if
the curve were a straight line,
d phi / ds would be 0, because
phi would be a constant.
d phi / ds would be 0, and the
curvature of a straight line
should be 0.
At any rate, one defines d
phi / ds to be the curvature.
And, in fact, to play
it safely, since s
can have two different
senses-- in other words,
why couldn't somebody
else say why don't you
go this way along the curve, I
don't know what the sense is?
Usually what one
does to play it safe
is we put the absolute value
signs around d phi / ds
and just call the
magnitude the curvature.
And the punch line
is that once I
call d phi / ds the curvature,
what I wind up with is what?
Just substituting in here now,
the acceleration vector is d^2
s dt squared times T plus
kappa ds/dt squared times N.
By the way, this entire
recipe is derived in the text.
I have you do it again as a
learning exercise because I
want you to practice with this.
And I make additional
comments on this in the notes.
The textbook makes
additional comments on it
in the text, which is where
you'd expect it to be.
And all I want you
to see is that this
is the same acceleration
vector that we were talking
about in the last
lecture, only now
we're talking about
how it looks in terms
of tangential and normal
components instead
of i and j components.
OK?
And what's so good about
tangential and normal?
What's so good about
tangential and normal
is that you're now
moving along the curve
rather than with
respect to some isolated
x- and y-coordinate system.
By the way, in the last unit
we showed a rather interesting
result, that if T was any
vector function of the scalar x,
and the magnitude
of T was a constant,
then dT/dx was
perpendicular to T. That was
an exercise in the last unit.
Now, the interesting point
is that the modern approach
to calculus says
this-- why should
we single out the xy-plane?
After all, you can be given a
particle moving through space,
or you can be using a
different coordinate system.
The natural parameter
is arc length.
Consequently, the
modern approach
never talks about the angle
phi or anything like this.
The modern approach simply says
this-- define the unit tangent
vector as before.
Because the magnitude
of T is a constant,
since dT/ds is already
perpendicular to T,
let's define a second
vector N to be dT/ds divided
by its magnitude.
Again, the same old trick.
What have we done here?
We have simply
taken dT/ds, which
we know is perpendicular
to T-- any scalar
multiple of the dT/ds will
still be perpendicular to T--
but now this is what?
It's a unit vector because
we've divided this vector
by its magnitude.
Therefore, N is a unit vector.
And where is it?
It's perpendicular to T.
If we now cross-multiply,
notice that dT/ds is equal to
the magnitude of dT/ds times
N. See, just cross-multiply.
I now claim that the magnitude
of dT/ds is just d. phi / ds.
Now, why is that?
I guess I should have
planned this better,
but let me come back to the
previous board over here.
Notice that since T
is a constant vector,
since T is a constant
vector, how does it change?
It can't change in
magnitude because it
has constant magnitude.
Therefore, its only change
must be due to direction alone.
But the direction of
T is measured by phi.
In other words, if dT/ds
is changing at all--
in other words, if
this is a variable,
it must be changing
only in direction,
because the magnitude
of T is always 1.
In other words, T cannot
change in magnitude.
It must therefore change
only in direction.
In other words, the
magnitude of dT/ds
is the same as the
magnitude of d phi / ds.
Recall that we just defined
the magnitude of d phi /
ds to be kappa,
and therefore dT/ds
is kappa N, the same way as
in the traditional approach.
The beauty of this approach is
that we're no longer restricted
to the xy-plane.
We're not restricted
to any plane.
We're not restricted to
any coordinate system.
We can now, in fact,
generalize this to go out
into three dimensions.
And, in fact, some
of you will probably
have enough difficulty
with what we've
done so far that you won't want
to go into three dimensions.
What I've done is I have
made up an optional unit that
follows this one, a unit
which has no lecture.
It simply has a
batch of exercises
for those who have mastered
the material in this unit
and would like to
see what happens
in three-dimensional space.
And, after all, when
you deal with real life
orbit-type problems
and things like this,
notice that you do
need the geometry
of three-dimensional
space for this.
If you so desire, you can
then do the optional unit.
That's why it's called optional.
You can skip it if you want.
There's no loss of continuity
if you should skip it,
but in that optional unit I
devote computational drill
to what happens when
our curve happens
to be a three-dimensional space
curve-- in other words, a curve
that winds through space.
Notice, by the way, that
in the same way as before,
I can write R of t is x of t
i plus y of t j plus z of t k.
where that is the
vector form of the curve
in Cartesian coordinates
given in scalar form
by the three equations,
x is some function of t,
y is some function of t,
z is some function of t.
Again, my claim is that
if I just take the dR/ds,
I still have the
unit tangent vector.
And to see that, just notice
what we're saying here.
This is a space curve now.
I've taken a small
segment of it.
Here's R, here's R plus
delta R, so this difference
is delta R. Look what
happens as you take delta R
and divide it by delta s.
First of all, the
direction of delta R
does become the direction
of the tangent line
as delta s approaches 0.
So certainly we can believe
that the direction of dR/ds
is going to be the
tangential direction.
Also, if we invoke
the result of geometry
that we talked about in
part one of our course,
when we talked about
sine theta over theta
as theta approaches 0,
the length of the arc
is approximately the length of
the chord for small segments.
So, therefore,
delta R over delta
s in magnitude approaches 1.
In other words, dR/ds is
still the unit tangent vector,
the same as before.
Again from a computational
point of view,
to find dR/ds you do not
rewrite this in terms of s.
You simply do what?
You take dR/dt,
the same as before,
divide by its magnitude, and
you automatically have dR/ds.
Similarly, once T
is given, to find N,
you simply differentiate
T with respect to s
and divide it by its magnitude.
And again notice, even
though I've written it again,
if you look back to the first
third of our blackboard,
this is the same
definition for N
as before, because our
original definition did not
specify that the curve had
to be in a particular plane.
See?
The same general definition.
So I now have T and N.
Now what do T and N do?
T and N determine a plane.
It's a plane which we call the
osculating plane to the curve.
That's the plane which
sort of touches the curve
at that particular moment.
Remember, this curve is
winding through space.
And, again, this is done in
more detail in the notes.
Not quite as elegantly
as going like this,
but the idea is you
have this plane that's
shifting along with the curve.
The only thing that's
missing that causes
new complications when you
deal in three-dimensional space
is that in the same way that
T and N take the place of i
and j in two-space,
you need something
that takes the place of k
in three-dimensional space.
What we do is-- again
look at the structure--
we mimic how k is related to i
and j and invent a new vector
called the binormal,
hence abbreviated B,
which is simply defined to be
T cross N, the vector that you
get by rotating the unit
vector T into the unit vector N
through the smaller-- namely,
the positive 90-degree-- angle.
Now what is B?
B is perpendicular to both
T and N. In other words,
B is a vector which is
perpendicular to the osculating
plane.
Since B always has a
constant magnitude,
because T and N are always
perpendicular-- see,
B always has magnitude
1-- the point
is that dB/ds, the
magnitude of dB/ds,
measures the twist of the curve.
In other words, here's
this tangent plane
following a point, a
particle, along the curve.
And what you're
saying is how fast
the direction of that
tangent plane is changing
is measured by dB/ds.
That is called the "twist."
I call it the "twist."
I put it in quotation
marks because nobody else
calls it the "twist."
The formal name
is the "torsion."
See?
This is called the torsion.
I talk about that
more in the notes.
The point being,
by the way, that
notice that if dB/ds happens
to be 0-- in other words,
if B happens to
be constant-- then
the curve lies in the plane.
We certainly recognize that.
For example, if the curve
happens to be in the xy-plane,
notice that if T
and N were i and j,
i cross j would just be k,
B would then be a constant.
The derivative of a constant
with respect to any variable
is 0, and, therefore, when the
curve does lie in the plane,
the torsion, the twist, is 0.
In other words, the torsion
does for three-dimensional space
what the curvature in a sense
does for two-dimensional space.
At any rate, our
main aim is to get
you familiar with some vector
calculus, and if in doing this
we can also help
you learn how to use
this stuff in some
physical applications,
that happens to be
frosting on the cake.
Next time, we are going
to talk about the fact
that we still have to invent
additional coordinate systems,
that i and j isn't enough,
T and N isn't enough.
Next time we're going to show
why we need polar coordinates,
but we'll worry
about that next time.
Until next time then, goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.